my name is Lyle I've been a screenwriter
for the last year started getting paid
work within the last year before that I
I wrote a lot of play script I wrote for
a lot of local theater groups um but I
always wanted to I always wanted to
write a film I was aware that there was
a lot of moving parts but it was
something I wanted to do my current
script I've been working on for about
three months so not very long the reason
the wait is the first one that I've
written to the end is because I I just
always figured that I'd right maybe like
a sci-fi ER and an action or run or a
horror or so because those of her kind
of films they grew up liking and I just
kind of got this feeling when I got to
about page 15 or something with just
like this this movie already exists and
this one the one I finished is um is a
is a Rome romance um drama which I had
no sort of experience in writing before
and just started writing it worked on it
for about six hours a day every day
within about two weeks I was finished
sat on it for another two weeks and and
then came back to it you know I don't
know whether that was because my um that
I didn't have very much attachment to
the genre or a lot of experience in it
maybe it gave me a different different
kind of fun perspective on it one of the
lessons that screenwriting has taught me
is that you're going to have to make
compromises and when you have to make
them you have to be able to identify
your um your voice as a writer so say
you write a script and say it's got
three locations and seven characters and
you manage to sell it and and you know
the producer likes it but then you get
some feedback other factors coming like
budget and you have to run you have to
change the set pieces you have to cut it
down to one location you have to cut it
down to three characters which you will
have to do in
you know and whatever way these
compromises come about um and when you
have to do it you have to recognize the
sense of humor the characteristics of
you as a writer that um that made your
your script special in the first place
because people aren't really going to
care about the you know the peripheral
details there they're going to gravitate
towards the characteristic um you know
your your personality the personality
that you put into the script and you you
kind of just have to be aware enough to
know it is